incredible and I was expecting a
handshake a couple moves ago I think you
called it frustration the only reason
that Hikaru keeps this game going
because objectively
to win this game would take literally an
act of God
and even Rook G7 King F6 Rook F7 some
tactics can help probably
just exactly because you feel like your
opponent is only lying on his active
Knight on F4 the last active Knight
let's not grab any more material let's
just get rid of that Knight and that's
it
are we entering territory Peter where
you're surprised at this point that
hikar is still not resigning
okay I'm surprised already for very long
time but it's it's not about Chess this
has nothing to do with chess you know
almost exactly yeah
in the previous game and Hikaru has
resigned his game Hikaru has resigned
there is the Victor pragna Nanda Hikaru
quickly leaving the board
incredible moment pragnananda knocks out
Hikaru Nakamura
and he does it in phenomenal mature
professional Stellar precise Style